[Music]
be ready
that's pretty cool you can see airbrush
made-up cars across the street I've
never driven in a foreign country before
no I'm not think about the water park
I'm just thinking about driving fill
what our German drivers like totally
fine I mean like super super careful
mostly but they also like to yell a lot
so I can't believe that putting chakra
island into Google Maps
I've been hauled though I have no idea
like an early-morning trip to the water
park let's hope we make it there alive
[Music]
are you feeling so far Andrew it feels a
little bit like we're in New Jersey
right now so I feel good
wow it really does so you don't feel
like you're about to crash this yet I'm
feeling pretty good
cut to a civic just crash do you like
waterslides Phil yes from 6:00 a.m. I
think are they fine with us coming yeah
yeah absolutely we have to be a bit
quiet when we enter why do we have to be
quiet because people are sleeping but
they're hoping right and early oh man
this is a new record there will be
people in there like camping in there
like sleeping at TPC tents
why yes
[Music]
and 7:00 a.m. on a Thursday and the
parking lot is already kind of full it
literally looks like something that was
set by another planet it looks like if
Matt Damon had stayed on Mars a decade
longer in your face Neil Armstrong
[Music]
with each good yeah I think it's time to
put our swimsuit I think it is they're
gonna stay three days it was reading the
slides steep and gray out and the
toothpick she said that we shouldn't
bring the GoPro on the big slide because
it's too dangerous
which makes me want to bring before
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
how will we rent the slide I'm gonna go
Steve Andreea toothpick okay no one
knows the things except for you yeah
we've established but so the red yellow
and the blue
I grew that how was it Phil okay at this
point I've honestly forgot where I am
it's weird to think I'm in the middle of
Germany and it's freezing cold outside
then real beats you were afraid you to
step in like broken glass and this
[Music]
we've been here for like two hours and I
can totally understand this is basically
the future the future the only thing
that I would change about it is that
they should pretend like we are on Mars
right now if I were to come back
I would totally walk around in my own
spacesuits look at Phil over there it is
so not impressed with this water park in
the same way that we are right now
[Music]
[Music]
No
[Music]
[Applause]
I was already sold on this part
nice how do you feel okay that's a good
good tip yeah there is I wonder how the
idea came about it's like oh you know
what this domes really big warn you but
you're okay okay we're about to now
we're good being lowered
how do you feel
that's like it's hard to stand right now
there were definitely two times where we
thought we were gonna walk that's it get
out of me I love how we were ranking the
water slides earlier like this is just
on a totally different level imagine if
we told that six-year-old Liz that when
you're an adult you're going to go to
this place that's the best waterpark
you've ever experienced it has a hot air
balloon and you can have ice cream for
breakfast it's all of my dreams and I'm
just too delirious to realize it that
was absolutely incredible Phil what'd
you think
it's okay
[Music]